concerning new data from the cdc
suggesting coronavirus cases in the u.s
could be about 10 times higher than
documented
now this comes as california becomes the
second state in the us to reach 400 000
cases
new york as you know was the first
yesterday more than one thousand
coronavirus deaths were reported
according to johns hopkins now that's
one of america's highest single day
death tolls
since late may tony in his first white
house coronavirus briefing
in months president trump sharply
changed his tone stressing the need to
get recent outbreaks under control
he also issued this stark warning about
the virus
some areas of our country are doing very
well others are doing less well
it will probably unfortunately get worse
before it gets better
something i don't like saying about
things but that's the way it is
the president appeared on his own
following weeks of criticism over his
response to the virus while he's only
worn a mask
one time in public he did encourage
americans to cover their faces when they
can't social distance
to help slow the spread of the virus cbs
news chief washington correspondent
major garrett joins us now major good
morning we heard the president say for
weeks
essentially this is all going to just go
away
now we have a significant shift in tone
at the briefing what do you think is
behind that
well i know what's behind it based on
conversations with republicans who are
working day in
and day out with the trump re-election
campaign with senate republicans who are
now
very much worried that their senate
majority is in jeopardy because of the
president's sliding
popularity and approval ratings
essentially anthony
if you were to replay that briefing and
subtitle it
that thing where the president said
worse before it gets better is
essentially the subtitles would read
like this
the poll numbers are real my prospects
for re-election are dimming
i have lost the confidence of suburban
swing voters across this country
and i have got to speak candidly and
honestly to them to get a chance
to win them back before the november
election that essentially is the
political context behind this
advisers the president have been telling
him this for weeks bill stephens a new
campaign manager
i'm told he's had some more updates
proper
interaction with the president
persuading him about the underlying
polling data
kellyanne conway has been a strong voice
for this the president made the decision
he's trying to change the tone but for
americans and for those concerned about
the future of the pandemic
policy has to change as well we have to
stay tuned for that
yeah what's the significance major if
any to the fact that the president
appeared at this briefing alone none of
his
health care advisors
that he owns this particular problem
that he has to take political and policy
responsibility for where this is
and that he's going to be in charge of
this new tone and this whole new
direction
saying he's working with governors no
dismissive language about schools being
fearful about reopening
talking about the importance of wearing
a mask telling youngsters hey don't go
to crowded bars
the president was saying none of those
things even three or four days ago
now he has he has reset or attempted to
reset
the political framing and the policy
framing around his response to the
pandemic
because he knows he is in genuine
trouble he tweeted a photograph of
himself wearing a mask but do you think
he's likely to
to do that actually in public major
we certainly created more space for him
to do that and carrying it to the podium
yesterday bringing it out brandishing it
for the reporters saying i would wear it
creates a space for him to do that and
it also sends a message to those
in his base and within the republican
party who have been resistant to masks
and these other initiatives to take the
virus as it
is right now more seriously a signal
that they now have political cover
who do they have political cover from
the president who's no longer sounding
as skeptical as you did
even a week ago that could change policy
at the local level as well give them
maneuvering room to be more specifically
uh from a policy perspective engaged in
public health initiatives to slower to
slow the spread of the virus the
president essentially giving them
permission to do things
he was not rhetorically giving them
permission to do a week ago
the white house knows if things don't
start happening at a
positive level at the state and local
level to combat the virus
that will redound not to the local
officials
detriment but to the president and he
needs them to change the direction
of this virus and he's giving them
permission and the rhetorical space to
do that
major quickly where do things stand on a
new relief bill there's
republicans in the white house are
talking there's a lot of disagreement
what's on the table basically right now
the senate republicans are trying to
hold the line they are divided among
themselves
senate democrats are very unified
republicans are trying to hold a line
about a trillion dollars there'll be
more money
for education there'll be more money for
ppe there'll be more money for
retrofitting businesses
there'll be some liability protections
but the white house will not get the
payroll tax cut it won't there's no
support for that
all right major garrett thanks major